[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
trop vite on rigolait un portefeuille
je veux tu joues par lequel elle n'a pas
non plus
[Musique]
elle va tout venu pour danser qu'une
gamine mais comme elle sans lui ce monde
la phase i je voulais pas aller
à tant d'années
j'essaie de faire le riche de souvent
sourire de faire le tri vous n'allez pas
tant d'années
je savais que deux idées souvent sourire
malade parce qu elle est tout et bobines
sont des baguettes caron
s'en fout des risques on n'a pas passé
tout est ok on s'en fout des risques on
a pas mal
la ville est ma voiture a connu et qui
peut pas changer parce que tu mettais
quand je ne te connais tu continues tu
sors jusqu'à quand
raccompagné one up ses rangs c'est bon
elle a vu tout l'oseo
à partir de là
[Musique]
je sais faire
la terre
et on verra
à toi
on s'en fout du risque
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]